[Musique]
je vais procéder à la vente de tous vos
biens je vous laisse encore de moi c'est
2 4 2
qu'est ce que tu peux faire en deux mois
rien tu peux rien faire mesdames et
messieurs je vous demande d'accueillir
la grande terre paulista wright
j'ai quelque chose à vous proposer un
bon travail et d'un cadeau mais j'ai un
élevage de vaches laitières
je me doutais cabaret pour montrer que
quand tu allais pas mort avec vous je
peux y arriver alors que les choses
soient bien claires je ne participe pas
aux travaux de la ferme
ceux ci sont un an rarement petit déj
pour moi 2 l'artiste c'est moi et 3 je
ne couche pas
à pôle emploi il me donnait plein de
contacts d'artiste génial la région donc
l'idée c'est de faire un cabaret le
premier tir baril à la ferme de france
j'ai cherché on n'a pas d'autre a fauté
s'est demandé pourquoi vous êtes le
souci de dalida et luigi c'est moi et
pas mal l'abandon il faut vraiment que
je te parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous vous attendons nombreux pour lui
premier cabaret à la perle de france à
david et puis faire de toi bon vieux
temps des pâquis ce que je pense est ce
que vous êtes soubresauts
[Musique]